hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra's never seen it's the
start of December Christmas holiday
movies whoo and today I am watching the
lovely heartwarming clip clips McClaskey
lastik die hard a company reached out to
me for me to talk about them and I'm
pretty excited about it one because
people watch my videos too because it's
a really cool company and three I didn't
think of it three okay so the company is
called graphics taka calm and they are
the Internet's largest provider of
graphics and images and photos that you
can legally use in a review or a video
or anything you're putting up on your
YouTube channel a yearly subscription to
graphics comm is usually $99 but they're
doing this holiday extravaganza discount
or it's $50 off which is pretty
substantial $50 off of 99 you do the
math because I honestly can't leave a
link to that it's in the description and
here is die hard Oh cameras never seen
it was okay I was expecting to think
that that was great in action because
everyone says is the best action film of
all time
but it was so great in action and it was
the greatest action film of all time
also I think that we need to have an Ono
counter because my notes are filled with
me just saying oh no oh no oh
literally the first note oh no trim the
beard oh it's so Bruce Willis is
visiting his wife Holly and I guess
they're estranged she got a job took the
kids to go work and he wasn't super into
her having a job more complicated than
that but that's the little lump of it
he's not happy about her working enough
to ruin their relationship but I
shouldn't be too hard on him he's coming
to visit for the holidays which is good
see your kids on the holidays death
important and to get in he has to let
use this touch screen and he's so smug
about this touch screen he's like a cute
toy Pete boop beep bop boo like it'd be
one thing if it was something that just
never came to fruition there was no
touch screens ever but there's touch
screens everywhere
everywhere to in my immediate grasp my
phone and this can this camera so maybe
keep an open mind Bruce Bruce gets the
party also I know I'm calling him Bruce
and that's his real name in Holly Holly
and that's her character name hi I mean
we met my name's Tamara this is what I
do
and this guy comes out to man kisses him
on the cheek and he's like Oh California
this movie is already super ATZ Oh gay
people
this must be California he couldn't
leave his job in New York and she really
wanted to go do this job in LA and he's
upset about that cuz it took his family
away from him and that's frustrating he
just has a lot of emotions and I get
that I have a lot of emotions - it's
okay Bruce I wrote oh no holy squid
Batman bad guys kill all the front door
men and holy young alan rickman whoa yes
alan rickman you can get it I wrote her
emoji times a million you've been
millennial so they're looking for
Holly's boss say get him and Alan and
the bad guys are looking for money if
the boss won't give it to them so they
shoot him so Jon be a New York cop he
sees all this happening and he goes into
survival mode and it's super cool from
the get-go he sets off this fire alarms
like all right great fire guys are gonna
come fire guys being the technical term
that you use he kills the thug that
comes up to get him and then he sends
him down the elevator but he's on the
elevator and he's like tallying how many
bad guys there are and getting their
name so he can mess with their heads
John sends out a broadcast trying to get
help and backup and police officers to
come aid in the situation then they said
the cop to go do some recon and who is
it it's Carl Winslow that's who oh yes
but at this point all the bad guys are
coming up to the roof to get him and
he's like climbing through these like
vents and then he takes his gun and he
secures himself and like climbs down and
like jumps to this other side and oh no
it's very stressful also at this point I
needed to go get another snack because
obviously and I pause it and it was like
still an hour and a half left of this
movie that was already so stressed I
don't even know what this is in
reference to this note just as holy shit
oh my god oh Lord
out then he gets shot at through the
vents oh sweet mother of cats it's also
what I broke I was on fire that was
directing these notes today I think I'm
just gonna call him Carl Winslow Carl
Winslow comes and John tries to get his
attention not successfully don't just
drop the body on his car cuz you know
effective also what is Jesus's middle
name because like four times already
someone has said jesus H Christ
is it Hoover Jesus Hoover Christ Jesus
Howard Christ Henry
Jesus hip hip hip hip eponymous Christ
then you hear the awesome line yippee
ki-yay motherfucker
oh this is in my notes this is who where
I realized that it was Carl Winslow
I didn't it right at first it just says
Carl Winslow
I'm loving my notes in this episode Iike
also Argyle Johns driver is still
chillin in the lot waiting for him to
call and say if he needs to go or not so
it's a pretty chill job mark I'll keep
that as long as possible so Paulo Carl
Winslow is talking to John on the radio
that he has and John isn't telling him
that he's a cop and I don't understand
why he's withholding that information
because Powell's commander-in-chief he's
like a boss is there and he's an idiot
and he doesn't believe Powell when he's
like yeah he's probably a cop because he
seems really smart and he's like no
people do things our way so we're cool
tough la cops and it would like all be
way easier if John would just be like
actually I'm a cop I know exactly what
I'm doing and you're an idiot I don't
understand that at all oh no oh no the
tank car blow-up scene they send guys in
and then they just blow them up the bad
guy terrorists just blow him up I say
him but there could have been like 20
people in that tank Oh No
oh my god and then John throws the
computer with the explosives down the
elevator shaft
Oh No stressful then you see Dwayne the
police chief Powell's police chief being
the actual worst he's the worst and then
John just roasts the crap out of him
through his walkie-talkie yes if you're
not part of the pollution the pollution
you're not part of the pollution then
good for you cuz blue shits a full if
you're not part of the solution that
you're part of the problem
owl no Dwayne up with names words are
hard this is one Ellis who is the guy
who wants to be with Holly is like let
me take care of it since your husband is
messing everything up remember lamina
Ellis is the worst I know I said Wayne
was the worst Ellis and Duane are like a
conjoint worst team then agent Johnson
and Special Agent Johnson no relation
shows him to take over because Dwayne is
the worst maybe I should have the worst
counter too too late oh no it's too big
then you see Hans
trying to put explosives who will you
find out is explosives on the roof for
later and he leaves his gun and he just
goes up on his little merry way like
this is gonna be fine and John is like
no it's not alan rickman you're fine but
just it's a parks and recreation quote
which is my favorite show in the entire
world so they go back and forth alan
rickman hans is like oh my name is clay
and i'm a good old-fashioned american
but john knows the whole time and he
gives him a gun but it's not loaded and
then he tries to shoot him it's just
great it's a great scene it's so good
also I haven't mentioned so far the no
shoes thing but it's so good it's such a
good touch such an uncomfortable bitch
that you're like what just never leave
anywhere without your shoes always wear
shoes shoes
so all of the posse comes up to save
Hans and John gets glass in his feet and
it's just stressful you can feel the
wrap-up of the movie kind of happening
and John apologizes to Holly through
Carl through the walkie-talkie he's like
please tell her this carl winslow just
being carl winslow is like you'll get to
tell him yourself buddy i love that part
then some reporters find out who John
and Holly are that they're both in the
building and that they have children so
they decide to go tell the children
what's going on and interview them and
put them on TV and it's so irresponsible
it's so annoying I don't I don't enjoy
this part at all in a good way because I
know I'm supposed to feel things bad
things about these reporters but I just
I don't it's not good journalism I don't
I don't like it not one bit and then
that ends up ruining everything because
then Hans finds out that Holly is his
wife so Holly is right here and Hans
goes mrs. mcclain how nice to make your
acquaintance like into the ceiling that
was so dramatic like 100% for dramatic
effect
and I loved it so they're still bad guys
amuck everywhere John gets shot in the
shoulder by one of them I've lost track
what's going on Oh No and then it's just
a mess of like John trying to get
everyone off the roof because now he
knows there's explosives there and the
cops are in helicopters and they think
he's the bad guy cuz he's like shooting
everybody to get down and they're
shooting at him and it's just oh no and
then this is the most badass scene ever
and that's just science folks that's
just science they explode the roof the
hostages are safe John is still there
because the police are shooting at him
so he ties a hose a fire hose around his
self he jumps off of this giant building
and then he's like hanging there people
are shooting at him he's shooting in to
a window like breaks it in they flies in
but then the fire hose like thing is
like pulling him back and he like unties
himself and it's very aggressively
stressful so cool oh I
in my notes then whyatt whoa wah which
is another Parks and Rec reference you
haven't watched that you need to watch
the show then why it always what look
wha oh that's the sound I wanted to
convey while tracking my hips I'm so
sorry but alan rickman saying EPK a
mother father is way way more satisfying
than bruce willis saying EP calle mother
for both very satisfying but Alan
Rickman that's my argument so Jon shoots
him saves Holly and Alan Rickman falls
out of a window so all the policemen are
outside and they just see Hans falling
out of the window and crashing on a car
and Dwayne goes oh I hope that's not a
hostage it's not Dwayne John and Carl
Winslow have a really nice a moment
where they're like you both like they
both each other they got each other
through the night and it was super cool
thing he knew exactly who he was when he
walked up it was really great
well-written point and then Dwayne and
decides to get into John's face it's
like all these things happen because you
got in the way police were blah blah
blah blah ended then this was the most
unexpected part of the entire movie for
me was one of the bad guys somehow
survived to something good he followed
up a window I don't even remember at
this point but he gets up off of the
ground pulls out a gun and Carl Winslow
if he doesn't just take care of business
like the Carl when somebody hits and
shoots him and there's this great
backstory about how his character like
shot a kid he and how he hasn't been
able to shoot anyone ever since so he's
been doing office work um but to save
his great friend John he shoots the bad
guy and it's brilliant and then a
reporter comes up and is like asking
them questions in their face and Holly
just decks him decks him in the side of
the mouth it's excellent my notes say
WTF so good it keeps getting better
oMG they kiss oMG at this point I'm not
even writing sentences I'm just like Oh
our guy was like if this is your idea of
Christmas and I've got to see your new
years I'm like if this is your idea of
die hard than I've got to see every
sequel ever invented also I think it's
just hole
Arius that he's allowed to just walk
away they drive off like an entire
building is exploded and there are many
dead bodies but they were like we're
just gonna go but I'm wondering how the
sequels work in this universe is it kind
of like taken where it's like this
shouldn't happen more than once but they
somehow made it I've got Christmas
movies that I like guys I like Krampus
I like Krampus this is such a good
Christmas movie I saw that it was 2
hours and 15 minutes and I was like oh
oh oh my life is hard but it was amazing
next week I'm gonna do a hopefully
awesome video on something that the
black nerd is going to just be delighted
about it was actually his idea don't
forget to go to graphics stock.com slash
holidays for $50 off oh the weather
outside is frightful oh and I has no
intention of being here having to be
she's such a good card with graphics tax
calm slash holidays okay see you next
week